[Music]
hello once again my name is c.a murray
and we welcome you to i'd like to know
our bible question and answer
program where we have the opportunity
the privilege of answering your
questions
as they pertain to the bible our
spiritual walk our spiritual life and
our spiritual growth i'm in the company
of friend and colleague pastor daniel
miranda daniel good to have you here as
always thank you pastor murray good to
be here yeah we we have a good time on
this program we we smile a lot and
though we are dealing with serious and
weighty subjects they are subjects that
we love to discuss love to study so you
see us smiling at us a lot not because
we are not taking them seriously but
because we have the joy of answering
your questions and the double joy of
digging into the word of god and that
that makes us uh very very happy you
will note that pastor voor is not uh
between us today he is he is out taking
care of some things a busy man so we are
left to hold on and to hold forth and it
is a pleasure to work with pastor daniel
uh and with pastor bohr we get along so
very very well the rumors i must admit
are true we do like each other and we do
get along with amen so we praise the
lord for that
should you want to get in on the fun we
encourage you to do so by writing to us
at tv
at some tv that is s-u-m as in mary tv
dot o-r-g tv
at
we will add your questions to this
fairly impressive list uh stack of
questions that we have and get to them
as soon as possible so do not be
dissuaded do not be discouraged if you
don't hear your
question immediately we've got quite a
list to get through we will get to your
question we promise and if an answer can
be found in the word of god we shall
indeed find that answer and bring it to
you that is our privilege that is our
pledge that we will bring you answers
from the word of god and from the word
of god exclusively and only
not the will or way or words of men but
the word of god because that is what you
need and deserve in these last days amen
we will start out with prayer and my
friend pastor daniel if you will do that
we will launch out into today's program
amen
my pleasure let's pray
dear heavenly father
we seek thy face we seek thy
understanding
we seek thy wisdom
as we try to answer these questions
we admit that we do not have
the wisdom and the light to be able to
interpret your word correctly
so we ask for the guidance
and the assistance of your holy spirit
that inspired bible authors and that is
also available for us so that
we can
rightly answer
the questions that you people have sent
us
we pray all these in the name of jesus
amen amen and
amen um you've got some questions today
this first one
uh let's see i don't have oh yeah
daniel
writing from kenya
i've had the privilege of being in kenya
and uh very strong
adventist community there very solid uh
community of uh
growth we have a couple radio stations
in kenya and uh we're glad that uh they
are tuning in
uh to secrets unsealed and some tv
our pastor
writes daniel
started teaching prophecies and other
teachings like the existence of demons
from the book of jasher
and enoch the books of jasher and enoch
he reiterated that since the bible in
the book of joshua mentions the book of
jasher he has jasper but it is jasher
then it's enough proof for us to quote
from them
and believe in them
pastor what do you think what do you say
well i know you have some you have done
some research in regards to these books
but i would like to contribute
or to make my contribution saying the
following
the fact that
some bible authors
quote
some books that we do not have today and
are not canonical doesn't mean
that these books are inspired
we have
a lot of references both in the old more
in the old and then also in the new
testament to extra biblical
references
for example um
if we were to
take
the sources from which bible authors
quoted as authoritative
then we would have to take
some of the
greek
literature also as authoritative because
apostle paul
while he was in athens he quoted one of
the greek poets yeah and we find it here
in the book of acts
verse
let me
uh acts 17 and beginning with verse
24.
uh but paul paul is saying here
beginning verse 23 for the context
now for i as i was passing through and
considering the objects of your worship
i even found an altar with this
inscription
therefore to the unknown god therefore
the one whom you worship without knowing
him i proclaim
and to you
and then in verse 28 he gives a
discourse and then verse 28 he says
for in him in the unknown god we live
and move and have our being
as also some of your own poets have said
for we are also his offspring
so he's quoting here one of the greek
poets
and and he's extracting what he said
what he believes
is in harmony with what he is teaching
and he says for we have also in him our
being our offspring so my point is that
the fact that we have
references to certain
extra biblical sources in the bible
doesn't mean that those sorcerers are
are authoritative
we see that also in some of the writings
of ellen white where she quotes from
non-biblical sources and where the
source goes awry she goes around that
and then picks up it on the on the other
side a couple things come to mind in
luke chapter 16 think it's around verse
24 or so
um the story of the rich man and lazarus
is is reciting
that is based on a a belief that was
generally held by
uh ancient israel that if you do good in
this life you don't do so good in the
life to come if you do
bad in this life and there there is a
a story that was fairly commonly known
called the the poor man in barmagen and
that was based on on that uh this idea
of uh
dip your finger in the water and cool my
tongue this great gulf fix so as the
story is told you know it's not it's not
true but it was it was told for a point
some time ago i remember hearing a a
pastor preacher sermon and he quoted
from a disney movie called the lion king
now
he was trying to prove a point
but do we
go out and watch disney movies or you
know run to walter no we do not um so
many times things are referred to and
because they are
referred to passively or in passing
doesn't mean that we should use that to
buttress our points or quote from that
uh
you may be trying to make a point but
you don't want to use that uh as part of
your your your presentation certainly
not to draw doctrinal points exactly
from from something that is not
canonical you know in reading this and
we were talking about this just before
we came on air um our pastor started
teaching prophecies and other teachings
like the existence of demons from the
books of jasher and you know well you
don't need to go to jasher and correctly
to produce to understand uh you know you
start in genesis yes you got demons you
know you it go to revelation you got
demons you know so you don't need to do
that throughout the gospel you've got
you've got demons
our safety is staying with the the word
this is not part of the word this is a
word it's not canonical it has been
rejected and i don't i would feel very
leery of exposing my church to too much
of this stuff
one they may start searching it on their
own and not know which is truth and
which is a lie and then two there's
enough truth in the word of god to to
see us through to heaven we don't need
to go in fishing in strange waters
trying to pull up uh
catfish and other kinds of unclean fish
to try to feed our people with there's
there's plenty of good food in the word
of god amen you know i think that
there is a growing interest in some of
our brethren in these particular books
because we have received a lot of
questions and also in spanish yes in
regards to the book of enoch
not so much on the book of jasher but on
the book of enoch
because
some of the bible authors quote them for
example jude it is believed that jude in
his epistle he quoted
the book of enoch when he said that
enoch prophesied the seventh from adam
yes about the coming of messiah and we
don't find that reference in the old
testament but again as you said the
bible is enough the scribes were very
careful
when they
put together the old testament during
the inter testament period
and they were very careful in
introducing what they recognized as
inspired from god and we don't have any
reference
from
the historical sources
that these books were considered by the
jews
as inspired
sources now you you were mentioning
something before we were on air pastor
ca
that the book of jasper actually we
don't have the
the original copy today the one that
we have today is a verge yes the the the
one that is is
fairly common today is a forgery from
the 1700s right from 1751. the original
book of jasher has been lost to us yes
it evidently contained songs and some
psalms and some some readings but the
original text no longer exists the one
that uh
exists today and carries the same name
is a fairly recent uh addition to
literature and i put that in quotes from
the mid-1700s so it's not only is it not
canonical it's not authentic it's a
forgery and we don't want to we don't
need to go to
false sister and the bible says to to
get our water and so um i would be very
very careful about quoting particularly
from jasher which is not is not it's not
real it's a forgery yeah and we need to
stay away from that again you've got 66
66 books of pure and living water amen
why go to the dead sea to get your water
you know
stay in stay in jordan yes stay in
galilee don't go to the dead sea and get
your water that's right
praise the lord amen
all righty uh good question this this
next question uh daniel comes from jay
just says jay
and um
james and ellen white uh jay i don't
know if it's jay yearwood i don't know
if it's he or she uh both state that
some of the remnant will be working when
he returns
it would be nice to have your thoughts
on this as as it is an aspect that is
not discussed
yeah i don't know if he meant james and
ellen white or jesus and ellen white
james i meant jesus jesus
jesus
well
the question is
a little bit difficult for us because
he doesn't give us the references
from where he thinks that jesus and
ellen white
uh concluded this
and also
what kind of work
he is referring to
definitely and this is common sense when
we study bible prophecy
after the sunday law
or to be more specific after the clause
of probation
we don't we don't see god's people
working in secular jobs
i mean um the if the faithful ones
uh the faithful ones will be sealed and
after the clause of probation they they
will have to flee yes some of them will
be in prison some of them in the cave
some of them will be fleeing to the
mountains
so
they won't be
working now
if if the person means that they will be
working for jesus
yes definitely they will be the work of
the gospel will end at the close of
probation
and jesus when he returned
to heaven he told his disciples occupied
like come yes occupy doing what doing
his work here on earth
i think
and i would invite jay uh yearwood if
you don't hear the answer that you you
you seek
rewrite the question with a little more
detail because it's kind of general and
you can go in so many many
directions
certainly the church will not always
remain in the laodicean mode that it now
finds itself amen we know there's going
to be a loud cry we know there's going
to be a
pouring out of the latter rain and the
church will really
jump into high gear before christ comes
again and when it comes the the greater
part of the church in fact every true
saint will be doing something for the
lord amen uh this listless attitude that
sort of earmarks the church now will
give way to a frenzy of activity for the
cause of christ uh ushered in by by the
loud cry and
the outpouring of the holy spirit of god
so the church will be working christ
will find the church ready waiting
working doing what it can of course a
lot of things are going to happen uh
people are going to be put in prison
people are going to leave the cities
people a number of things are going to
be happening but the work of god will
continue right up until the close of
probation yes so we know that as so so
that is what you are speaking of then
that is certainly true um if you're
talking about
day-to-day secular jobs and occupation i
think you explained that quite well um
so there's a change there so perhaps uh
we may need a little more nuance as to
exactly where you're coming from on this
because uh we are not quite sure and we
want you to be sure uh that you're
getting the answer that that you want
but um those are our thoughts as far as
we can understand the the the gravitas
of your particular question and we we
will if we didn't say it like you want
ask it again and we'll try to do the
best we can
but um certainly god's people
are called to work now and to continue
to work until we move from labor to
reward that is our calling and that's
what we ought to occupy ourselves in
doing amen
okay do we have another one daniel
indeed we do
uh let's see this is from is it e-m
e-m yeah well
i'm ca so i guess we can have e.m
this is revelation chapter 17 verse 12.
so i'm going to turn to that
while i am reading
uh and the ten horns without thought are
ten kings
which have received no kingdom as yet
but receive
power as kings one hour with the beast
and the reason i always
turn is because sometimes
our writers in their haste
and in their exuberance
do not quote the text
exactly as they should but this person
has done a pretty good job
the ten horns which you saw are ten
kings
who have received no kingdom as yet but
they receive authority
for one hour as kings with the beast
what are we saying on that one dan what
do you have so the question is if
um
who are these 10 kings and when will
they receive the kingdom
well this is a whole study on
revelation
17 which i believe pastor bohr
did a
a series on for the anchor bible school
where
he touched on this i think is
that the the series is called from
the clause of probation to
to the end of time something like that i
believe it is close to that yeah it's
close to that yes
but
we'll try to answer this briefly but if
our answer is not satisfactory i would
encourage you to go
to this series where passover will
explain this in more detail
now when we go to revelation 17
we see
some symbols we see a woman
that is a harlot we see a beast
and that beast has seven heads
and ten horns
and
the ten horns are
or the beast the heads and the ten horns
are described from verses 7
through 15.
now
i will go really real quick
and because of time i won't be able to
prove everything
with other bible references
but for example here in verse 7 we see
the mystery of the beast
and this beast has seven heads we
understand that the seven heads
represent the seven
uh world kingdoms
that
satan has used throughout history
to set up his kingdom beginning with
babylon
the mark references daniel bobby lomito
persia greece
pagan rome papal rome uh we have five
and then the sixth head is the united
states that comes into the scene
revelation 13 13 11 verse 11 exactly so
we have
there the six heads when it says one is
is referring to the sixth one okay five
have fallen one is which is united
states and then there is one to come
so there is a there is a
a relationship or a connection
between
the seventh head
and the ten kings why do i say that
because
here
speaking of the kings
or the ten horns in verse
12 it says the ten horns which you saw
are ten kings
who have received no kingdom as yet
but they receive authority for one hour
that's a short time as kings
with the beast
so the ki the ten kings during the time
of inactivity of the beast this is the
time of the of the deadly wound
that the beast is not that is that means
is inactive right
but the one that is is active that is
the united states so while
the beast is inactive
is not
the united states
is active and history confirms it
because you're talking about the late
1700s
and the beast got the wound healed
ladder and pack 1929 or so
and of course during that
lollan activity that hiatus of the beast
the united states comes into existence
and becomes a world power so it's
confirmed by by history exactly
so
during this time which is the setting
for this vision uh john was taken to the
future
this these ten horns are future
as well as the seventh head because the
seventh head it says here that
um five
five have fallen verse 10 one is and the
other that's the seventh has not yet
come and when it he comes he must
continue a short time so we see the
connection both the seventh head
and the ten horns are both future
both will reign for a short time so the
seventh head is the same power as the
ten kings i would i would conclude that
the ten horns are not distributed as in
the pictures that we see yes that are
distributed in the seven heads but are
actually in one head and one head in
this in this case the seventh head
which
we understand that it it represents the
nations of the world
because the number seven is is
perfection or totality
uh and we know that at the end of time
all the nations of the world will
join with the papacy and with the sixth
beast that's the united states
to persecute god's people so
in conclusion
uh the ten horns
i believe are
all the kingdoms uh in this case 10 is
also totality all the kingdoms of the
earth
that will give their power to the beast
yes i i think
this is a
a visual representation of what has been
said
so many many times before in so many
many different places but you've got
a series of world kingdoms that are gone
you've got one that is on hiatus and
when it comes back
it is being supported by
all of planet earth as far as uh the
powers are concerned so i i agree with
you wholeheartedly that those those ten
horns are
part of that that that seventh one um
and um it's a visual revitation of
what's going to happen just before just
before the time time of of the end
it's i i'm not sure exactly uh if
there's a question
rather than an explanation of what
what was seen
but they received power one hour with
the beast
and of course that is before the
ultimate destruction of the beast
this is going to happen they're going to
rule they're going to reign they are
going to hold sway for a short time this
these last movements will be rapid ones
yes that's right and
the this this coalition will not be
allowed to be in the ascendancy
century upon century upon century as
we've seen in the past these things are
going to move move through quickly and
then god is going to stand up as he uh
predicts in daniel 12 and
save his people and bring an end to all
of these things then of course christ
will come and bring it into this age
it's a good question it's a question
that
bespeaks study and
we thank
em whoever em is
uh we thank you for
for your your question
yeah just a final note on this
uh this prophecy is being fulfilled
right in front of our eyes yes because
we see how the world
and especially during the pandemic we
could see it even more clearly
how
uh
you know
in the crisis that we are seeing in the
world with uh with the climate change
with the pandemic
with the wars and rumors of wars
the nations of the world
look for guidance
look for the pope for guidance and for
assistance so the pope or the papacy is
gaining ascendancy and influence more
and more as we reach the end of time yes
and all these crises that are happening
in the world are for
their advantage
one of the things that we as human
beings have a tendency to do
we like to have one person speak for
everybody you know we like to get our
answers from one person
when i was taking a course
working on my degree in crisis
management
they used to tell us if you have a
problem at your company
find one person and let that person
speak for the company don't have this
person speaking and that person speaking
filter it all through one people because
news media likes that so the first thing
for crisis management is find a face
get that space to speak for the company
and to do all of the speaking so that
anytime anybody wants any information on
company a
we go to daniel miranda because he's the
spokesperson well it's the same way with
uh uh uh
the world and the world situation if if
the pope says he has the answers we like
going to one person take all your
questions to that one person and we see
this in in in our world today if you are
a charismatic leader people will follow
you yeah particularly if they have
questions for which they don't have
answers and you say i've got the answer
they'll listen
because they don't have any answers so
we are seeing a dress rehearsal in our
world right now for what's happening yes
you can see it right before so when when
you see these things look up the bible
says you know for your redemption duroth
night don't be surprised
uh because uh it's happening right
before our eyes again these are great
great questions these are questions that
we speak fought and
you're in the word of god and we are so
thankful that we are able to wrestle
with your questions answer your
questions these are exciting things to
study and exciting things to fortify
ourselves with because
a test is going to come to everybody and
you need to know the word of god for
yourself uh
without a knowledge of the word of god
you don't even know what promises to
claim when trouble comes so it fortifies
you to meet the challenges and to be an
overcomer amidst the challenges which
will surely come our way the bible tells
us that everything that can be shaken
will indeed be shaken and your time of
testing and shaking
is on the way we pray
that through the grace of god you will
be able to stand stand firm stand strong
and stand until jesus comes again well
our time has fast slipped into eternity
a lobbying closing to with you grace and
peace through our lord and savior jesus
christ we'll see you again soon bye bye
and god bless
[Music]
you